what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpour with my first avatar video
I love avatar and I'm glad to finally be
making a video on it this definitely
isn't the first anime channel to cover
avatar even though it's not technically
an anime but that doesn't really matter
if we all love avatar so if you do want
to keep seeing avatar videos on this
channel be sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future avatar videos there will be
all kinds of spoilers so you've been
warned about that now without further
ado let's jump into it before we get
into the interesting specific bending
styles let me just mention that there
are five broad bending powers airbending
waterbending earthbending firebending
and energy bending then within those
categories there are interesting and
more rare sub bending styles that we'll
get into not everyone in the Avatar
world is a bender and only the Avatar
can bend more than one of these broader
categories in fact avatars have the
potential to learn all of these broader
bending styles and as you probably know
already
bending means being able to manipulate
the element in question so let's start
with airbending which is associated with
the nation of air nomads the flying
bison shout out to Appa we're the
original airbenders airbending is
associated with freedom and the season
of autumn it's direct opposite is
earthbending airbenders tend to be
focused on speed and evasion airbending
allows one to manipulate the wind in
order to attack defend evade and even
fly most airbenders use a glider or
special outfits in Legend of Korra to
help them fly around but two airbenders
in history have been able to fly like
Superman without needing gliders or
special suits these two were guru
laghima and Zaheer from Legend of Korra
it was said that guru laghima spent the
last 40 years of his life without ever
touching the ground like Superman asked
flight spiritual projection is a
specialized airbending technique that
can be learned by special airbenders
like Jinora this technique makes it
possible for a person spirit to leave
its physical body temporarily allowing
them to travel underwater through walls
or to hone in on someone who they have a
strong spiritual connection to notably
we've also seen airbenders travel on top
wind use airbending to create a barrier
of wind that serves as protection
against explosions or poisonous gases
create hurricanes and bendy air out of
someone's lungs thus we could say that
we've covered airbending and two
additional subsets of airbending
including a kind of gravity bending that
lets people straight up fly and the kind
of spirit bending that lets a person
soul leave its physical body next let's
look at waterbending which is associated
with the Water Tribe it's direct
opposite is firebending the original
waterbender was not an animal but the
moon which is pretty unique and
interesting water benders are known for
being versatile adaptable and turning
their enemies power against them think
of Bruce Lee saying be like water my
friend waterbending is known as the
element of change in its corresponding
season is winter unlike air benders
water benders are more dependent on
their environment having a huge body of
water to work with helps but skilled
water benders can also bend water out of
the air or out of living things like
plants water butters can also quickly
turn water into ice and vice versa as
mentioned water bending is associated
with the moon so it is stronger at night
and especially during a full moon but
the ability disappears during a lunar
eclipse and if the moon spirit dies the
sub bending skills for water benders are
healing and blood bending blood bending
is especially interesting since it's
like a forbidden jutsu in Naruto
it's been called the darkest most
powerful and most feared type of bending
it allows humans to control animals
and/or other humans by controlling the
blood in their bodies the user can
manipulate their victims as if they were
puppets the technique was discovered by
waterbender Hama when she was in a Fire
Nation prison Katara helped to outlaw
blood bending but that did not stop
people from using it altogether
originally Hama and later Katara needed
a full moon in order to blood bank
however later on the criminal yacón
learned to use what bending without
needing a full moon
yacon could even render people
unconscious through his use of blood
bending and it took an avatar mode Aang
taking his bending powers in order to
finally stop him
still yeah Cohen managed to escape from
prison and had to blood bending sons
Noah talked the older sibling grew up to
become a mom as a mom he could use blood
bending to counteract the blood bending
of others and even to take away a
person's bending
permanently however the avatar is able
to undo this and return the affected
person's bending powers next up let's
look at earthbending which is associated
with the people of the earth Kingdom the
original earthbenders were the
badger-moles earthbending is known as
the element of substance and it's
associated with spring as opposed to air
benders earthbenders had to stand their
ground their style emphasizes strength
and fortitude rather than evasion and
mobility earth benders have a special
connection with the earth and are
associated with patiently listening and
waiting for the right moment to strike
just think about how Bumi the king of
Omashu let himself be captured and
waited for the perfect time to strike he
waited until the day of Black Sun for
the firebenders to lose their bending
abilities and then single-handedly
liberated his city in minutes what's
more he was 112 years old at the time it
just doesn't get more legendary than
that like water benders earth benders
are pretty relied on the environment if
there is no earth around then normal
earth benders are pretty much powerless
that's why people used to use metal
prisons to hold earth benders but then
Toph beifong managed to learn
metalbending and so metal tends to be
replaced by platinum in the Legend of
Korra since no one has been able to bend
platinum yet in addition to metal
bending some special earth benders can
learn lava bending while a bending is
considered to be even rarer than metal
bending lava bending allows the user to
turn earth into lava and manipulate it
at will Lama benders can also turn lava
into earth although it is more common in
legend of korra lava bending was used
long before by the Fire Nation avatar
who came before Abbot our yang Chen and
then later by avatar kyoshi
when Chen tried to conquer her Peninsula
she used lava bending in order to help
split the peninsula from the mainland to
this day that remains one of the most
impressive things I've seen in Avatar
another sub skill of earthbending a
seismic sense which lets the user read
vibrations in earth and or metal this
ability lets earth benders detect
people's movements and locations Toph
could even use this ability as a lie
detector furthermore as an old lady in
the foggy swamp Toph could use seismic
sense to connect to the whole world by
using the roots of the banyangrove tree
in this way she can watch over her
daughter's even from ridiculously far
away the last general element
we'll cover before we get into energy
bending is firebending firebending is
associated with the fire nation and it's
considered to be the most aggressive
style of bending dragons were the first
firebenders which makes for a pretty
epic origin its opposite is water it's
considered to be the element of power
and it's associated with a season of
summer unlike earth benders firebenders
can produce their element from thin air
if there's already a fire they can
manipulate the flames but they don't
need a pre-existing fire in order to
firebend their power corresponds with
the Sun and is thus strongest at noon
and weakest at night firebending is not
possible during a solar eclipse while
its greatly amplified when a comet
passes close to the earth Iroh even
mentions during Sol's ins comet that
only once every 100 years can a
firebender experience this much power he
then goes on to fire flecks and is able
to straight up fire bent a hole into Ba
Sing se is a mosquito is that azula's
firebending is blue suggesting that her
flames might be hotter than that of
other firebenders sub-skills of
firebending include lightning bending
and combustion bending lightning bending
lets one generate and or redirect
lightning
it is so rare that for many centuries
few people even knew the lightning
bending was a thing nevertheless there
are quite a few characters who have been
able to use it throughout the series
Azula
Iroh Ozai and Marco in Legend of Korra
have all been able to generate lightning
then there's combustion bending and opie
ability that we've seen from combustion
man in the last airbender and from pali
in legend of korra this ability allows
this user to ignite things with their
mind each of the combustion bending
users we've seen have had what looks
like a tattoo third eye on their
forehead a kind of beam is released from
this third eye and it caused a powerful
explosion when it comes into contact
with something Polly could even curve
her beam allowing her to hit the enemy
from difficult angles the key to beating
these overpowered combustion vendors is
hitting them in the third eye once hit
the third eye will fail to work properly
for a while and it could even backfire
on the user and then there's energy
bending which includes bending the
energy within human bodies and use
energy bending to take away bending
power
and Cora used energy bending to return
people's bending powers after they were
taken away through the use of blood
bending and then things get a little
more crazy Cora used energy bending in
order to create a giant projection of
her spirit that could launch powerful
energy blast it was this ability to let
her beat the dark avatar in season two
in the final season of Cora Cora uses
energy bending to deflect an extremely
powerful beam from kuvira's spirit
cannon arguably the strongest weapon in
avatar lastly the user of energy bending
must have a spirit that is unbendable or
else they may be corrupted by the other
spirit as Aang almost was when he was
trying to take away ozai's firebending
and that is it for today's video about
every bending style ever let me know in
the comments what your favorite type of
bending is and what kind of videos you
would like to see next
if you did enjoy this video make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
and share it with fellow avatar fans if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future avatar videos lastly the
YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime upper
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and help
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledged by Lord we go himself every
day and the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Steven and Rana
Aloha Nintendo World Steelers acquired
respect but they have a Jonathan King
Dessie deep Brandon a Miles Papa Smurf
the school bus King riser emperor otaku
richie martinez and thomas jones and our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King's I'll just Anatoly kozloski angel
Cruz Cricut XP Joel Stanton very Gucci
Alicia actor
Jessica Calif on Kinoko me and water
Bonnie parks OD are 12 or two in day or
Tian Fong cynical crack and fungus 77
and Dudley Saints thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow outpour and becoming
a patient
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out Pete chong kham slash
anime I'll put a link in the description
if you're interested you can also now
join YouTube channel it's a for more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]